well I remember like when we were about
to do the Pilot We for Jackass I was
meeting with Jonas oand who was doing
like this punk rock he was trying to put
put together this punk rock circus I was
like Jonas you got to meet my friend
steo like he's a clown he's very good
you know we're about to do this pilot
but I don't you know I don't think it's
going to go anywhere really so like it
would be great for you to get Steve in
your circus I was just trying to get you
a gig cuz I thought ours was going to go
yeah well I appreciate that I remember
when when I first met you in person was
December 30th of
1999 Jesus was the day before
stalker it was the day
before day before New Year's the big Y2K
and I I had flown myself out to
California to do my stilt stunt with the
stilt costume on fire and the unicyclist
and the skateboarder jumping off the
roof of the house over my head through
the Fireball and uh I thought I was
trying to shoot a cover for Big Brother
magazine but when I got out there you
know here's Knoxville and traine I
forget if it was Ballard or you know but
and trinee said now that you're here and
I can tell you we're not just shooting
this for for the magazine we're actually
shooting this for a pilot for uh for MTV
and jackass wasn't even the name it was
just kind of an un
Untitled you know pilot from TV and you
guys had no idea what it even was I
remember before my still stunt like uh
you and I sat down on a like a couple
bales of hay in the back of this house
and like you kind of interviewed me we
didn't know of like if uh if it was
going to be like an interview the
subject kind of a thing before the bit
maybe you guys were toying around with
the idea of it was going to be like a
talk show desk kind of a thing cutting
to throwing to Clips but It ultimately
it just ended up being like okay forget
about a format just make it well we had
the we had the call a spike we're like
do it is there a sitting behind the desk
portion of the show or this or that and
he's like you guys are already doing the
show just make it like the Big Brother
videos yeah and oh yeah that's that's
where we're going with it um what was
your first impression of Steve when you
first met him uh he was very
excitable um and uh I mean I can be a
lot but steo could be a lot especially
when you were using um
and yeah I
remember when like we the on the show it
was like you
were not that I wasn't drinking and
doing pills we both we both were
but like you and I are always going
opposite
directions you
know I I that's a very kind way to put
it no no but it's like you were like you
just wanted to get smashed yeah and I
was just wanting to go to the bar and
you know yeah and have eight get
distracted with women or something yeah
I wanted to draw attention to myself and
you wanted to kind of duck out of yeah
the the attention and I was just a lot I
I I I was a lot um but you also knew
that you were aot it's not like and
that's that that goes a long way social
awareness of like knowing people are
getting uncomfortable yeah he at that
time he couldn't do anything about it
but I mean he knew he was alive but he
he couldn't calm himself down but then
it's just like you just learned like
that's how he is he knows it and you you
just love him you know the uh there are
times I remember just being like AR like
I remember multiple times where uh you
like not subtly not slightly like just
put like pills in in my food or you know
oh yeah just
like let me just stick two Xanax bars in
sto's sandwich right now blatantly like
he he knows they're there but just make
him eat these two genx bars just to try
to get him come down a couple notches
and even that wouldn't do it my one of
my favorite moves with steo I walk up to
him and I stomp on his foot he go ah and
then I pop up his XEX in his
mouth yeah that's amazing I think you
learned to stop giving me Aderall pills
but the XEX really didn't work either
you know it's just like yeah yeah you
don't strike me as somebody that ever
said like no no no I've had too much
like you probably just down to go
I was just gnarly and I think that that
over the years since then um I like I
I'm very happy to have been have become
an easier guy to be around oh yeah yeah
and and hopefully I have too because
like I I I had a a long way to go in
that area
um
just feeling like you like sometimes you
always need to be on and causing as much
chaos as possible because that's what we
did for a living and then it's like and
then yeah do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and good news is sto's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and steo butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude